the two people killed have been
identified as 47 year old Brent Hallett
and 30 year old Maurice digiovanni both
are from Las Vegas as far as the other
victims two are recovering at Sunrise
Hospital are expected to survive others
are at UMC one victim remains at this
time in critical condition another in
fair condition two victims have been
released from the hospital
when we're dealing with patients with
penetrating injuries such as knife stab
wounds or gunshots we talk about the
golden hour of trauma so most patients
with those injuries usually die from
uncontrolled internal bleeding so the
fact that those victims were able to get
here I think within 20 to 30 minutes of
the the incident happening played a
crucial role in in saving their lives
a GoFundMe has been set up to support
one of the families impacted by this
incident as well as helping the recovery
efforts for others wounded the owner of
the best Showgirls in Vegas opened it
for anyone who would like to donate to
the family of gigiovanni and she says in
the link that three other Showgirls have
been wounded in that very same incident
they will recover